welcome to gadget lab 2012 episode 1 I'm
Michael Cole or a I'm Mike Isaac today
we've got a little preview of the
Consumer Electronics Show mmm coming up
next week chugging emergency every
single day ah yes I started actually
giving it to myself intravenously nice
and then we're gonna have a take a look
at a red camera from John a really fancy
video camera for shooting hollywood
movies digitally is it actually read oh
no it's black and then christina is
gonna show us a new windows phone but
first let's talk about ces this is the
Consumer Electronics Show yes the yearly
event in Vegas that we that everyone in
the electronics and tech industry sort
of simultaneously looks forward to and
dreads right because it's where
everything comes out every year right
it's it's all of the big products of the
year yeah so everybody shows off stuff
you know to Shiva HP sony you name it
any company involved at all in hardware
will be there showing you everything
they're going to be releasing between
now and the holidays so it's sort of an
endless stream of stuff yeah and it's
our job as journalists to wade through
all of that and find the most important
things the most interesting things and
the things that make the biggest impact
on our industry and our lives and show
those to you so that of course is going
to be phones tablets intelligent right
the three things that we all use so what
are you looking forward phones this year
so this is going to be nokia but
basically the year that nokia and
microsoft are going big microsoft is way
behind in the smartphone industry right
right now obviously apple and google
dominate the industry apple still google
has you know its operating system across
myriad of devices across manufacturers
apples doing insanely well with the
iphone but microsoft and its windows
phone operating system has like
relatively no market
right yeah so people who like it dark
will use it like all right it's a great
operating system no it's super cool so
there's not very many good phones out
there right so so there has been no real
I mean HTC and Samsung and LG they've
kind of had like toes in the water but
they're pushing really behind Android
right so nokia the what are they Swedish
manufacturers different Finland oh jesus
oh my god that's so that's a comment
fest right there no all right no offense
simoni i love your meatballs or vodka or
whatever worst nokia is a plunging
headfirst into into Microsoft Windows
Phone OS so they are you know infamous
for the dumb phones that are everywhere
but they've never done smartphones we
call that we call them feature phones
right exactly but there's also a bunch
of ice cream sandwich stuff coming out
probably yeah at the same time androids
most recent operating system was
released over the Christmas holiday and
so a number of Android devices are going
to have to come out and start you know
upgrading to that eventually probably
from the next three months tablets
obviously yeah so we're gonna see a
bunch of ice cream sandwich tablet is
probably probably smaller form factor
Thomas yeah seven inches instead of 10
people don't like paying like tons of
money for things that so maybe three
hundred dollars tablets yeah somewhere
around there may be two hundred the
Kindle Fire did very well you know
obviously amazon is doing really well ya
know everybody wants to 200 all or
tablet right right which is hard to make
you know good yeah everybody also wants
a thousand-dollar fast notebook so I
think we're gonna see a lot of
ultrabooks at CEO these are you know
things that are basically following what
Apple did with the air which is make a
very light very portable laptop that
doesn't do everything but does enough
for around a thousand bucks most people
are trying to skirt it under that some
people are skirting in just above it but
it seems to be the sweet spot for
laptops nice also see us we're going to
be looking at green technology for the
home different ways
keeping your car on the road but without
without drink a saline right and we're
going to have a roundup of cool audio
devices of course there's always new
headphones speakers inside that yeah and
we're going to be looking at new fitness
devices so you can check out all that
coverage next week on The Gadget Lab on
wire calm and when we come back we'll
have more to talk about will be in Vegas
next week when we come back on mortally
isn't Luda and like 50 cent and all
those people doing a lot of the device
debuts for audio oh yeah sure right
thank you Chris yeah I'm serious yeah
yeah pity soon will be there I will be
hanging with them you know backstage in
the club right so now we're gonna go to
John we're gonna go to John Schneider
one of Wired's photographers and he's
going to show us around the red scarlet
X camera this is the latest high
definition video camera from red it's
the scarlet X the Scarlet X is
definitely catered towards the
independent filmmaker or any
professional who wants to upgrade a
high-definition video from the current
DSLR setup it's about half the price of
the epic red camera between thirty and
forty thousand dollars for that body
this is about 14,000 cific it red gave
us this scarlet X kit that came with a
125 g egg s SD card proprietary to them
this monitor handle grip some batteries
and they gave us one of their cine
lenses this camera is definitely geared
for professionals it's not for making
home movies it shoots at 5k which is
five times higher definition than 1080
HD the difference between a scarlet X
and the red epic is basically options in
frame rate capture with the epic you can
capture any frame rate at any resolution
the scarlet x can only shoot 24 frames
per second at 4k 60p at 2k and at 5k
you're only really pulling high
definitions
the dynamic range on the mysterium X
sensor that comes in these cameras it's
about 13 stops which means that can pick
up a lot of information from the darkest
shadow to the brightest pilot this
camera can be handheld but it definitely
weighs five pounds and probably about 12
with the lens on it this big stimulants
probably not the best thing to hold for
a long time I would definitely consider
investing in a red camera scarlet X
particularly it's affordable everything
is modular so as the technology changes
you can upgrade pieces and it's really
fun to use we're joined now by Christina
Bonnington at the top of the show we
talked a little bit about the
partnership between Microsoft and Nokia
to bring windows phone devices to the US
market and we have an impressive one
that you've been testing we do the Nokia
Lumia 710 this is brand new right just
came out it is it'll be available I
believe next week on tmobile on tmobile
for fifty dollars fifty dollars fifty
dollars and fifty dollars the best part
is it doesn't suck oh but wait there's
more but so what would uh what's special
about this phone like what's this is
part of the lumia series right it is so
it has a big sister the Nokia Lumia 800
that we reviewed recently and that one's
kind of more of a flagship a little bit
it's still not a hugely spec filled
phone neither is a 710 it's got single
core processor 5-megapixel rear-facing
camera 3.7 inch display so it's just
kind of it's like less than everything
else we've seen yeah but it really
doesn't need all those bells and
whistles it's a really solid smooth
experience everything works the way
you'd hope it would it does have
hardware buttons along the bottom
instead of capacitive touch buttons
which we kind of usually see these days
yeah it's it's a good deal it's
definitely a good bargain for fifty
bucks fifty bucks you can't go wrong
there
so one of the things that you mentioned
any review that I thought was really
interesting was that this is a good
phone for people who are sort of
smartphone curious right because it's a
windows phone you know I think a lot of
people who are still using I mean most
people in the world use use windows as
their main operating system so if you're
making the jump to smartphones is it
easier as a Windows user to have like a
Microsoft you know branded and Microsoft
designed experience on your phone so
it's definitely completely different
from like Windows 7 from like the
Windows desktop experience it will be
similar though to Windows 8 because it
has that same Metro interface and it's
just generally pretty easy to use you've
got these live tiles on the front and
tmobile added a few apps so it comes
with Netflix ESPN The Weather Channel
and a few other things there's an app on
here that lets you kind of just check
your account information really easily
how many minutes you've used up they've
made it really user-friendly and then
you've got these live tiles you click on
the update i can see what temperature it
is i can you get to my pictures really
easily so the cool thing about live
tiles is that they've really
incorporated a lot of the social
networking stuff that used to be apt
dependent into the operating system
right so you've got right Twitter and
Facebook and all that stuff on like
actually baked into the OS right from
the get-go right right so that's in
what's called people hub and it just
collects all of your social media
streams if you click on a particular
person it will show you all your
interactions with them your emails
tweets Facebook status messages and
stuff so it's really nice to see how you
interact with your friends the only
problem I had with it really was that
sometimes it didn't like when I clicked
on the links it took a few tries policy
which kinda actually makes me feel like
I'm a robot or something like why
doesn't my finger work the screen
doesn't understand urgency and the
harder you press it doesn't go through
any faster yeah well that's that's
pretty cool and there's more coming this
year from from
the Nokia Microsoft partnership for sure
right yes what do you think we're gonna
see the 800 stateside it's available in
europe now right i don't know i mean i
would hope I mean it's already January I
was hoping you know februari but tough
to say thanks thank you very much well
well I'm on the edge of my seat that's
all for this week next week we'll be at
the Consumer Electronic Show but we'll
have tons of video and tons of posts and
tons of stories and tons of photos
coming from the whole team she'll be
there I'll be there Michael be there
John will be there so you'll get to see
our smiling faces whether you like it or
not and then we back in the studio the
following week so until then bye bye